in the previous video i asked you to
solve this
let's see how this can be solved one
thousand and two cubed here the number n
is one thousand and two the number is
near one thousand hence our base will be
one thousand and the deviation d will be
two these are our three parts n plus 2 d
3 times d squared and d cubed n plus 2 d
is 1 02 plus 2 multiplied by 2 here it
will be 3 times 2 square and on the
right we'll have 2 cubed the answer for
this will be 1006 just remember that the
number of digits in the second and the
third parts will be equal to the number
of zeros in the base so three digits in
the second part and the third part three
times four is twelve because it's three
digits we write it as zero one two two
cubed is eight hence we write it as zero
zero eight and yours are answered in the
next video i will teach you how to
easily find cube roots for more such
interesting math concepts do subscribe
to our youtube channel
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below